they kind of send you out the room and
you're just stood in the corridor being
like did i pass did i fail oh my god i
failed i failed spectacularly of course
i failed
and it's like the worst five minutes of
your life before they like call you back
in and then like the senior professor
sort of sat me down and said
congratulations dr smithers and i was
like i'm gonna cry
hold it in front of the senior professor
so at oxford where i did my phd they
have this really cool tradition that you
pop a champagne cork into the ceiling
tile when you come out of your viper
[Applause]
and you sign your name next to the dent
that you leave and you really get to
like leave your mark on oxford physics
which is so cool i got it first time and
literally i think i was more scared for
that for my vibe i was terrified of it
ricocheting off the ceiling and hitting
me in the eye like fully like nightmares
about having a black eye on the day of
my
bible that was handy thank you
it's also a binary dent which is an
astronomer i was really quite happy
about it
so both the both ends of the champagne
cork dinted into the ceiling because the
champagne cork came out and then came
horizontal so it looks like a little
binary star in the ceiling oh well done
are they unusual or yeah i think so
so i was born in preston uh raised in
chorley so this is lancashire i went to
school in bolton and then i went to
physics with astronomy at durham
university i was like six years old and
wanted a telescope for christmas kind of
thing like i was always into space like
space books on the shelf getting little
telescopes always wanting to go out and
see the sky but i hated physics so up to
about gcse i couldn't stand physics
forces and light goes in straight lines
just didn't hold any interest for me at
all and then it took getting to gcse and
starting to do astronomy and
radioactivity and things like this that
made me realize that i absolutely loved
it it's the sheer scale of space that i
thought was awesome you read in your
space books about jupiter is so much
bigger than earth and this is how much
more massive the sun is and this is how
far away the moon is and you think it's
a kid wow you can't even imagine those
distances and yet you can go outside and
still see it in the sky just blew my
mind yeah i got a little thing it was
like a
um i don't even know how thick it was i
think it's like a one inch refractor or
something it was tiny but it was really
cool i could see the moon basically and
jupiter looked like a bigger bright spot
than it did with your own eye but it was
still amazing to have
i actually wanted to be a pediatrician
at one point
i also wanted to bring a marine
biologist
because i loved dolphins and wanted to
work with dolphins and then my mum told
me that don't be ridiculous if you're a
marine biologist in the uk you just take
river samples from the thames all day
and that would be all you do not
realizing that i could move outside of
the uk to do that and that also as an
astronomer i am probably now going to
end up doing that as well
so at durham i did physics and astronomy
because i knew astronomy was something
that i loved i always wanted to do the
astronomy modules so i got to do
things like measuring the temperature of
sunspots
at durham in my second year we took
solar telescopes out on the grass in the
science site and people looked at us
like we were crazy but i thought it was
great
i got to use the telescopes on top of
the roof as well you know shoveling
six inches of snow with a broom off the
telescopes in my third year on every
clear night you could get which meant
sacrificing a lot of nights out as a
student but it was worth it in the end
end of four years you're thinking what
on earth do i do now everything up until
that point has been so sort of
prescribed a little bit you go to school
you do a-levels you go to university and
then you're just left
to your own devices and everyone's going
off and applying for grad schemes so you
think okay i'll apply for a grad scheme
sure and i ended up in the september
working at rolls royce on their
engineering grad scheme because
i never thought really sat down about
what do i want to do and then it took me
till about november to december to
realize that
i missed astronomy so much
like it didn't matter that i was kind of
doing the same thing every day sat at a
desk and going through data and you know
just talking to people about science it
wasn't astronomy it wasn't the same
thing and i missed it so much that i
started applying for phd positions in
the january
applied five different places so uh
manchester bristol
durham again oxford
four different places i had interviews
at all of those places
um not just an interview to say do they
want to work with you but also do you
want to work with them you know your is
going to be a supervisor for three years
you've got to like that person
and
i was then just waiting
to see who wanted me where i wanted to
go
i got the call from oxford
that i had been accepted on a phd
whilst i was in bella italia in
manchester with my mum
and it was a very excited phone call
i was so happy the project there was
perfect it was working with galaxy zoo
which is this online citizen science
platform that gets the public to
classify galaxies which i thought was
amazing that i could
do research off the back of public's
efforts so my thesis was trying to
figure out why galaxies stop forming
stars
so you see a lot of blue spiral
beautiful galaxies and then you see a
lot of red
boring blobish kind of shaped galaxies
we call them elliptical galaxies and so
the idea is if something's blue it's
very hot it's star-forming it's got lots
of young stars if it's red it's kind of
dead and dying and there's not much
going on but the thing is you end up
seeing lots of red spirals and blue
ellipticals so it's kind of all tangled
together the shape that things are and
whether things are forming stars or not
so the idea was to use the public's
classifications from galaxy zoo and then
all our observations of galaxies to look
at this like statistically across a huge
population like as many galaxies you can
get your hands on and and see what was
going on
using big population statistics
things are more complicated than they
seem
that is definitely what i learned before
people thought there was these kind of
like two specific tracks that the spiral
galaxies go one way and the elliptical
galaxies go the other way when you look
at the whole population and use
statistics you see that actually there's
kind of this spread
of different rates that galaxies can
stop forming stars
and you also find that the black holes
in the centre of the galaxies play a
huge role as well and they could be
shutting down star formation really
rapidly and that also whether there's a
lot of galaxies around a galaxy or
whether the galaxy is isolated can also
have a massive impact as well and you
see that sort of in the statistical
results which is really cool
yeah this whole heft
of a thesis and in fact this is
double-sided and you have to print it
out when you give it in single-sided so
it's even higher than that when you give
it in and it feels like such a weight
and a meat of work that you've done what
do you think like an astronomer who
reads that will think okay that's new
information to me yeah i mean well
that's a definition of a thesis is that
you have to add something to the
scientific collective knowledge there's
lots of things i've added galaxies do
stop forming stars at different rates
there's not two clear channels that's
something new that people come to i
mentioned that black holes can have a
really big impact there's super massive
ones at the center of galaxies besides
learning a lot about star formation what
did you learn about astronomy over the
three years of your phd that there isn't
an answer and that's
where the fun bit is you know i got into
physics and astronomy and maths because
i liked it over english because there
was an answer but the whole part about
research is there isn't an answer and
astronomy is
beautifully complicated
and this
huge big picture that is impossible to
visualize as for one person
and that collaboration between people is
crucial in order to be able to figure it
out
yeah i mean the whole you know whatever
the astronomers ever done for us is is
such a repeated phrase in society and
it's not necessarily a direct thing that
we're doing you know we're not directly
curing cancer but the imaging techniques
that are being developed that we're
pushing forward to be like we need to
see deeper and further and more than
we've ever seen before are then applied
to things like mri machines and ct scans
that are then used in medicine you know
astronomers needed a better way to
transfer data so they invented bluetooth
and now every single person has that in
their pocket basically on their phone so
it's the kind of indirect things that
come from astronomy that are useful in
society but then also like
humans are naturally curious everybody
wants to know
where we come from and
how the universe is and what it's made
of and those answers are going to come
ultimately from astronomy
do you think most people in the street
are curious for those answers at the
level you're looking at i'd hope that if
you said to them
hey there's a black hole at the center
of every galaxy they'd be like really
cool i hope if you said to them you know
the universe started this way they'd at
least be curious enough to then ask a
follow-up question
even if they didn't understand it they
can still be like but wait what about
this
i'd hope that there was some vestige of
curiosity at the back of everybody's
minds
yeah i got this job and basically they
told me write up your phd as quick as
you possibly can
and so i wrote up in two months
with a 10-day holiday squished in the
middle as well which was quite fun
and ended at christmas which was nice
and then in the january 2nd of jan
packed up moved
started my new job on the third so the
whole point of this job was that i wrote
a proposal to say i want to research
this and then they picked it because
they thought that sounded cool and so
the research proposal is on this idea of
how do black holes affect their galaxies
do they
stop them from forming stars does the
energy output from the black hole sort
of move through the galaxy and you get
this sort of like wave of sort of star
formation stopping or does it put energy
out into the sort of surrounding area
which then cuts off gas supplies so
there's no more star formation this kind
of thing that's what i'm going to be
focusing on i'm going to be using this
really cool new instrument as well that
doesn't just take one picture of a
galaxy it takes 127 little ones and so
you can like
like sort of jigsaw puzzle the galaxy up
so that you can see like what is going
on in various different areas oh there's
loads of people working on this coming
at it from different angles like sort of
there's people coming in from the
simulation angle the theory angle
there's people coming at it from
different wavelengths as well i'm
looking in the optical in the uv and
there's people coming at it from the
radio the x-ray and even the infrared as
well so we're all working on the same
thing it's just you know to prove
something to prove a theory you need all
those little bits of observational facts
in order for it to sort of build up and
say right we're definitely sure of this
now the other part of this fellowship is
that i'm going to be working with 60
symbols and i'm going to be making
videos
about my research and
what i'm getting up to and cool things
in astronomy and what i think you guys
want to know about i've always been into
outreach you know any age basically kids
adults i think it's fantastic in for any
person if you can just help them
understand something like that light
bulb moment when they're finally like oh
i get it now is so gratifying as in as a
scientist that
you've made someone understand the world
that they live in
that's true but there's a subtlety here
which is that actually what you're doing
isn't the two body problems the two body
problem is if you have the sun and
something in orbit around it what you're
actually doing is a three body problem
you've got the sun you've got the earth
and you've got your satellite